comment relancer les commerces à la
campagne le gouvernement vient de
débloquer une enveloppe de 12 millions
d'euros pour faciliter leur installation
en milieu rural un coup de pouce que
n'ont pas attendu certaines communes à
habillent dans le Sud Touraine c'est
tout un village qui se mobilise pour
attirer des commerçants et ça marche
comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage de la Turquie
matinée bricolage à habiller objectif du
jour retirez les crochets du plafond de
cet ancien restaurant 6 habitants de la
commune se sont réunis pour l'occasion
j'aime bien aider pour pour la commune
pour redonner vie au bâtiment après ce
bâtiment c'était autrefois un lieu
emblématique du village le relais de
Touraine permet depuis 15 ans maintenant
une période beaucoup trop longue pour la
commune qui rachète les murs en 2019 et
décide de rénover pour ça l'organisme
quatre chantiers participatifs tous les
habitants volontaires se retroussent les
manches y compris monsieur le maire
du village et c'était important de les
réhabiliter donc il fallait trouver la
façon de le faire et ce qui compte c'est
trouver des courageux et puis après
d'être là pour pour répondre présent et
quand on a les gens après la commune se
doit de suivre côté finance le projet
est d'envergure 736000 euros hors taxes
avec une aide de l'état de 40% la
municipalité réussit son envie de
redynamiser son village l'ancien
restaurant deviendra donc extension de
l'épicerie et chambres d'hôtes pour
l'instant il y a plus lieu où les gens
peuvent prendre un café un thé se
croiser dans le bourg et puis dire bah
tiens je sais pas dire un café même si
ça va être beaucoup de travail voilà
c'est un vrai défi pour moi et je suis
content de le faire pour la commune et
les habitants nabilly le nom de la rue
du Commerce reprend petit à petit tout
son sens assistante maternelle coiffeur
loueur de vélo boulangerie et
distributeur de pizza ce sont tous
installés ici en quelques années
elle appartient tout entière à la
commune même le matériel
bah ça a été beaucoup plus facile pour
nous c'est sûr ça donne une dynamique au
village et bah ça redonne un peu de vie
donc ça se passe très très bien depuis
qu'on voilà depuis qu'on a implanté ça
au début octobre et avec le camping qui
est derrière les vélos la piste cyclable
à côté voilà il a la période touristique
qui va arriver ça va être très
intéressant pour tout le monde c'est un
service en plus des commerçants et des
habitants satisfaits à vie continue donc
sur sa lancée et espère l'ouverture de
l'agrandissement de l'épicerie pour la
fin de l'année